para que el valor de csx 3 un factor del
polinomio p de x donde px
este polinomio de aquí abajo es - x al
cubo más c por x al cuadrado menos 4 x
más 3 bien los invito a pausar el vídeo
y resolver este problema por ustedes
mismos
ok para resolver lo vamos a utilizar el
llamado teorema del residuo y que nos
dice pues en este caso en particular nos
dice que x menos 3 x 3 es
factor
factor de px
px y qué significa esto pues recuerden
que x 3 un factor de px quiere decir que
p de x puede ser escrito como x 3 por
algún otro polinomio ok eso significa
que x 3 un factor de px y lo que nos
dice el teorema el residuo es que esto
pasa si sólo sí sí solo si
el polinomio p evaluado en 3
en 3
lo pongo en rojo 3
es igual a cero ok eso es lo que me dice
el teorema el residuo y esto tiene
sentido al menos intuitivamente puesto
que si evalúo pd x x 3 es un factor de
px entonces p de x se puede escribir de
este modo y se evaluó este polinomio en
3 aquí obtendría 3 menos 3 que es 0 x
algo más pero no importa porque
multiplica 0 siempre me da 0 así que
esto es claro intuitivamente así que
bien vamos a evaluar el polinomio px en
vamos a averiguar cuánto vale este
número de aquí
decir me lo vuelvo a poner en rojo
no va a ser mucha talacha mejor me quedo
con el amarillo pd3 cuánto sería esto
pues sustituyó y obtengo menos 3 al cubo
más c por 3 al cuadrado menos 4 x 3
+ 3 y cuánto es esto
menos 3 al cubo sería menos 27
3 al cuadrado es 9 así que aquí sería 9
cm 4 x 3 12 + 3 y esto cuánto es menos
12 + 3 es menos 9 menos 27 menos 9 y
menos 27 sería menos 36 más 9 se ha
escrito de otro modo 9 c menos 36 ahora
bien si quiero que x menos 13 un factor
de x por el teorema el residuo es
necesario y suficiente que pep evaluado
en 3 que pd 3 sea igual a cero por lo
tanto voy a forzar a que esto sea igual
a cero y vamos a averiguar cuánto tiene
que valerse pues si espejo se de esta
ecuación digamos sumó 36 ambos lados
obtengo que 9 se tiene que ser igual a
y si 9 es igual a 36 dividiendo entre 9
obtengo que se es igual a 36 entre 9 que
es 4
se es igual a 4 de modo que
de modo que si px
si px es el polinomio menos x al cubo
más 4 c perdón más 4 x al cuadrado menos
4 x + 3
entonces x 3 es un factor de este
polinomio